we've already discussed that donald
trump uh
privately knows he can't win tomorrow
i'll have a more detailed report on that
for you
the the report from peter alexander is
that
trump realizes that he has no path to
overturning the results of the election
but he's doing it as theater the
lawsuits the fights the
uh seek seeking and receiving financial
contributions
it's theater but how is donald trump
really doing
the speculation of course is that donald
trump
is clearly damaged and triggered
he's barely been seen in public since
losing he did one press briefing last
week where he took no questions simply
saying
i won he briefly showed up yesterday at
a wreath-laying ceremony
for veterans day and because
we know about donald trump's narcissism
and being a sore loser and egomaniac
never apologizing never admitting defeat
one would
imagine that donald trump is not taking
this particularly well
well the washington post philip rucker
was on msnbc
yesterday and he's covered this white
house really well for years he has a
number of uh
of sources inside the trump
administration and philip rucker says
that the reality is trump is quite
fragile
emotionally right now take a listen to
this don't think it'll come as a
surprise to anybody
we haven't heard from the president this
week
we saw him today what's your reporting
on where he is on his personal journey
well brian his emotional state is quite
fragile we've not
seen or heard from the president in
several days with the exception of this
morning on a rainy day in washington he
went out to arlington
uh national cemetery to lay a wreath in
observance of veterans day but he has
not been doing much
governing as best we can tell he's
actually fighting hard to keep a job
that he doesn't seem
uh content to do at the moment rather
he's been
lighting up the phones from the white
house he's been calling
friends advisors allies uh in
in what one official describes to my
colleagues
ashley parker josh dawsey and myself uh
as a search for good news he's just
casting about for somebody to tell him
something good
uh so he can hold on to hope that he
might still win this election
uh even though the the reality the
numbers are are clearly against him and
he's starting to recognize that
so much so that he's talking about
running again uh in 2024 which if he
held on to any
uh any sense that he was that these
election results were going to be
overturned and he would be declared
the victor then he would not be talking
about a 2024
campaign uh but here we are that that is
what he's talking about
uh these last few days so it all makes
sense quite fragile
barely leaving the white house doing no
governing calling people
searching for good news to see if
anybody might give him some good news
and thinking about running again in
2024. so i guess trump's feelings are
hurt
but remember it's their side that always
says
facts don't care about your feelings
isn't it time to buck up
and accept the facts and this isn't just
trump this is the entire
right and say that he lost they lost
that's
it and there were i saw this hilarious
tweet yesterday
who was it that's it was like a both
sides thing
oh it was uh howard kurtz who i think
now does like a media analysis
show on fox news which is hilarious in
principle but
howard kurtz tweeted both sides see
and on one side you had
trump alleging that he really won
and then and refusing to allow the biden
transition to officially start
and then the example of the left was
that a whoopi goldberg i guess said
trump trump supporters have to suck it
up saying look both sides
hold on a second one side is the current
administration
refusing to accept that they lost a
presidential election
and interfering with the
president-elect's transition that's one
side
what you're comparing it to to say both
sides are doing it is whoopi goldberg
saying random trumpists should just
accept that
trump lost both sides give me a break
and i i was again reminded of that right
wing
of refrain facts don't care about your
feelings these are facts guys
trumpists are going to need to suck it
up and accept the fact that donald trump
lost
and at the same time at some point trump
is going to have to accept
that joe biden is president of the
united states it could take months
into biden's presidency before donald
trump accepts it now i do want to talk
about one other thing
i've not heard a lot of discussion about
this we do have a national security
vulnerability right now that has
developed
the reality is that donald trump really
hasn't been doing his job as president
for a long time
punted on coronavirus he's almost
exclusively been campaigning for months
there really hasn't been a president for
a while
but we now have a more acute national
security issue because
trump is doing no work trump reportedly
hasn't been even receiving his
presidential daily briefing
and when trump was getting the pdb he
didn't pay attention
he didn't read it sometimes he would get
distracted by a tv with fox news in the
back of the room
but donald trump is also not allowing
the president-elect joe biden to start
receiving the presidential daily
briefing now ideally
normally in every other transition the
president
is getting the presidential daily
briefing and the president-elect
also starts getting it and that way you
have a smooth transition when joe biden
comes into office on january 20th
he's aware and up to speed about
everything that's going on terrorism
national security threats etc
we have a situation right now where for
at least two months
no one is really getting the
presidential daily briefing trump is
president he's not getting it
biden is president-elect he's not
getting it and on top of this we have
the report from philip rucker
that donald trump's emotional state is
quite fragile right now
so if you're a rogue nation if you're an
adversary if you're an enemy if you're a
terrorist organization
you know there is a window of
vulnerability here for the next two
months
and maybe for some period after as joe
biden
gets settled and gets up to speed on
everything the us
is likely more vulnerable than usual
this is an invitation to do bad things
for lack of a better term
it is globally known you need no sources
you don't need to eavesdrop on anything
it is globally known that right now
there's a total absence of leadership on
national security
nobody's getting the pdb at the highest
levels of government
anyone who would want to do us harm can
just turn on tv and realize
what's going on very disturbing all
because of donald trump's fragile ego
and lack of willingness to formally
admit defeat and
sign off on joe biden starting to get
the presidential daily briefing
it's disgusting if you are anything like
me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns send
prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video